on the mound for the halos record of two
and four and a four point seven seven
era right-hander jaime berea there we go
jp crawford first pitch up the middle
base hit that's a good start
man jp 11th hit on this road trip and
being aggressive and he's on right away
for seattle and ty francie's
10th in the league in batting average
hitting 293 he'll be the next batter
that one's hit to jack oh he grabs it
goes over to fletcher and turns the
5-4-3 double play that is big well even
though there was a little bobble by
mayfield after he got the ball to
fletcher he's got that quick release at
second and france
was an easy out as it turned out on the
back end of that double play ball so
here's kyle seeger getting ready to bat
he was over four last night
that's well stroked into center field
cutting it off his marsh a two-out base
hit for kyle seeger a couple of hits in
the inning get things started for the
mariners crawford erased with a double
play then a solid line drive from kyle
3-2 payoff rudder on the move fly ball
hit to right center field this one is
carrying pretty well out there jumping
up and making the catch will be marsh
he might have taken a home run away
right there it looked like the glove was
above the yellow line out there in deep
right center marsh had a beat on it all
the way we're watching the replay and
yeah that ball would have left
so the inning ends on that deep drive to
the angel center fielder and tyler
anderson who was acquired from
pittsburgh july 28th
and this season seven and nine but two
and one with the ends he throws a lot of
fastballs two scene four team cut
fastball
87 93 miles an hour my go-to is to have
success against anderson tonight as you
have to look and try to be successful
with life in the fast lane it means
getting one of those fastballs 74
and blast one of those middle of the
zone chain jumps he's giving up some
home runs versus change up eight of them
but it's a middle part of the plate and
that's a base hit
nice job for brandon marsh
i mean have yourself a knight he keeps
that little hitting streak going that's
now a six gamer for him the angels have
the first batter on that brings up
shohei ohtani with marsh at first base
he's been walked 11 times in the last
three games
looks that one right field line into the
corner good speed from brandon marsh he
is being set by butterfield orton he's
going to third the throw to third base
so johnny is
is he out or is he safe he is safe
seeger drops the ball by time hanager
got to this
marsh scores easily from first to throw
from toro was the third base and it
looks like shohei barely gets in but
once again his momentum carries him off
the bag
and
kyle seeger
kept the tag and then dropped the
baseball so i think he was going to be
called out
and then once seeger dropped the
baseball they said nope
jocelyn that should score a run
and it does it is two nothing halos
nice job by the goose
good job by phil gaza with that infield
back just hit it to one of the middle
infielders and you're going to get a
free rbi with the speed of
ohtani stacy banning 251 12 home runs 33
rbis
anderson's pitch swung on ground ball to
short right there j.p crawford fires the
first in time to get stassi and then
will retire the side but the angels
early damage two runs on two hits
the next batter
renifo hits that one well
he's hit it deep
back to the wall and it's gone
for renee
nothing angels
this is a change-up it's center cut and
luis randhipo just waits for it to
arrive and then unleashes
he's got some pop
didn't miss it
cut into this lead three-nothing angels
here comes the pitch
swung on hard ground ball up the middle
this could be two picked up by fletcher
goes to second for one relay first not
in time crawford is safe scoring is
frayley so the mariners on the board
raleigh erased
4-6
choice rbi
it's 3-2
ohtani
[Applause]
back triples for show otadi and he
scores marsh again
and it's four to one what can he do
that's incredible now 97 rbis shohei
phil gazan on this home stand 212 home
run three rbis here's the pitch
hit hard right back up the middle this
will bring in shohei
bill gosling checks in with the hit
ohtani will stomp on home plate and los
angeles extends the lead it is five to
one angels in the third inning and it
has not been anderson's night so far he
has been rock solid for the mariners
this year but they are tagging him
pretty well tonight
jared walsh stepping to the plate
he singled his first at-bat hit the ball
hard
into right field
first pitch to walsh he hits it hard
into right field this one's going to get
down one run is in
here comes the other run the throw goes
to third base stassi beats the throw
and jared walsh
with that single drives in a pair gossen
from third mayfield from second and the
angels are piling it on right now they
lead this game
seven to one
oh two pitch on its way ooh
that one hits marsh with on the back leg
and that will drive in a run
full count bases loaded
walked him
that's another rbi
ohtani a basis loaded walk it is nine to
one angels as they keep pouring it on
here in the third inning ramirez oh two
gosselin to center field
it falls in front of them one run scores
another run scores
two knocks in the ending and another two
rbi for the goose gonna bring up jared
walsh he's got a couple of knocks
tonight and he's swinging at the first
pitch and he hits that one well kelly is
on his horse
one run is in
two runs coming in right now safe at the
plate it's 14-1
ohtani scores his 99th run of the season
02 to kellnick
got him
ball game first major league victory for
jonathan diaz
a 14-1
thrashing of the seattle mariners
evening the series at one game apiece
[Music]